Você já leu o rótulo do leite de coco
industrializado que está nas prateleiras
do supermercado em uma marca famosa que
eu olhei esses dias eu contei mais de 10
aditivos alimentares esse tipo de
produto que seria aparentemente saudável
vem carregado com uma série de
conservantes e aditivos que se
consumidos com frequência põe em risco a
sua saúde você já sabe que o leite de
coco natural é um verdadeiro Tesouro da
natureza mas Eis que surge o lado
sombrio da versão industrializada com
Anes como é o caso do ns22 que é o soato
de potássio podem provocar irritação
diarreia perturbações estomacais e até
enxaquecas o NS 2111 torna-se Ainda mais
alarmante quando combinado com ácido
cítrico ou ácido ascó bico que é a
vitamina C sintética podendo formar
benzeno uma substância cancerígena o NS
223 que é um metabisulfito de sódio pode
desencadear reações alérgicas irritação
gástrica e asma sendo especialmente
perigoso para crianças